everyone
it's very good to be back here uh i i
gave a tutorial back in 2019 when the
world was a different place i'm glad
there's still a world to come back to
and give talks to so welcome everyone um
with these tutorials it's kind of
difficult because uh there's always a
mixed background right uh
some of you out there probably know some
statistics and some machine learning and
some python and different combinations
of both so i'm not going to make any
assumptions about
your background knowledge here
this is meant to be a kind of a high
level overview of bayesian statistics
probabilistic programming and pi mc
so we won't go in depth into anything
this is kind of just a taste and um
there's lots and lots of resources out
there for you if you want to dig a
little bit deeper
um as matteo mentioned i work for the
philadelphia phillies which is a
baseball team in the united states we
are hiring by the way we get a good
office view
unless you don't like baseball in which
case it's kind of an obnoxious view
software developers
quantitative analysts data
engineers if you can throw baseball 100
miles an hour relief pictures we're also
looking for so let me know
um
so probabilistic programming uh isn't
really a new thing the the term is kind
of new
um and when we talk about a
probabilistic program we're really
talking about any computer program whose
output is non-deterministic or it's
partially determined based on the
outcomes of random numbers and so
um really it can be you can do pp in any
language that has a random number
generator but of course um you know some
choices of language language are better
than others
and
what we're really specifically talking
about here essentially is a language
where there are additional primitives
right we're so we're used to primitives
in the sense of integers and floats and
strings
um a probabilistic programming has
uh primitives that are stochastic so
uh objects that generate random numbers
uh have stochastic properties
um particularly from you know known
statistical distributions normal
distributions binomials things like that
so you know you can you could have an
object that has a normal distribution
you can draw a hundred random values
from that uh you can get um more
sophisticated than that there are
distributions over entire functions like
a gaussian process
where you can draw a function from a
distribution or distribution over
functions and make predictions on that
and then importantly
you can condition
one based on the other right so you can
have a variable that's drawn from one
distribution and then use that draw
to
condition the draw of another
random variable so what this does is it
allows us to
uh specify
statistical models probability models at
a very high level right it's all about
abstracting away a lot of this stuff and
the main reason we do probabilistic
programming is to facilitate bayesian
inference
and bayesian inference is probably
different than the statistics you may
have learned
at university although newer programs
are incorporating this stuff a little
bit more
why should we do what is first first of
all what i'm having said i'd make no
assumptions what is bayesian inference
what is bayesian statistics uh this is
andrew gilman uh andrew gelman's
definition and he's a prominent bayesian
out of columbia university he says
practical methods for making inferences
from data using probability models for
quantities we observe and about which we
wish to learn so the idea is you build a
model using probability distribution
everything
uh that you are interested in has a
probability distribution associated with
it and the probabilities that we're
talking about here are a little bit
backwards from
what you might be used to
so and in fact bayesian inference used
to be called inverse probability because
what we're going to do is we're going to
infer from
effects to causes
so y here is some data that you observed
theta
is uh
are unknown quantities random variables
predictions whatever you're interested
in and you're going to observe something
about the world and we're going to use
that to infer something about the things
you're interested in right
so it's these conditioning statements
that help determine what the causes
might be
why why would we want to do this uh
this is again a definition from uh
lincoln barker's book on bayesian
statistics um it's attractive because
it's useful
um you know there are sort of
philosophical
reasons that you might want to be bajan
rather than frequentist but
it's it's very useful and it's very
simple at least
conceptually it's very simple
all the pieces are very simple but it
can be used to build something large and
complex and interesting
so it's a utility really that motivates
me
here's the requisite showing of the
bayes formula right so this is what
we're doing here
we're going to use probability
distributions to characterize what we
know and don't know about the stuff
we're interested in again and again
theta here are the things we're
interested in could be one variable
could be 100 variables would be an
entire model
and so the idea is you you have some
some uh information about the world
before you start doing your experiment
or your project and and that's we
encapsulate that in a prior this is what
we know before seeing the data and then
we have some observations some data
that we uh encapsulate as a statistical
likelihood and we use that the magic of
base formula is that it it
we use that to update our information
about theta and give us that inverse
probability that i talked about before
so
after having observed something what
what can i say
about about theta
and this so this is really just a rule
for learning from data and that's really
what machine learning is trying to do
all the time
so um
in probabilistic programming we want to
come up with a a program that does this
for us
uh because that's kind of the hard part
in bayesian inference is the actual
calculation of that posterior
distribution
and in a stochastic program what we're
doing is we're specifying
most of the
right-hand side of that equation so
we're going to give it information about
our prior we're going to get information
about the data
and you model this kind of joint
distribution of your data and your
unknowns
so let's look at these pieces a little
bit so prior distributions um
again we're trying to quantify the
uncertainty in the latent variables
before we've we've seen the data we may
not know much about it so we you know
everything has to be given a
distribution in base so we might give it
a a normal distribution which is you
know your bell curve maybe a mean of
zero and a standard deviation of one
um
it says that we know essentially it's
somewhere between negative four and four
perhaps
um
this is also a normal distribution that
line across the bottom
uh
so normal with mean zero but a standard
deviation of a hundred so variance of
ten 000 it's essentially a straight line
in this region and that means we don't
know very much about it right it's
diffuse it's uninformative largely
uninformative
um
often we know something about the system
we're studying right so let's say
something like i don't know an
infectious disease that ravages the
world uh its prevalence is going to be
low even during a pandemic right so a
beta distribution describes things
between zero and one so a rate can be
either be anything between non-existent
to everywhere zero and one and even even
uh a prevalent disease is going to be
you know
10 or less most of the time
so that's a beta 150 so this is again
characterizing what we know ahead of
time
then we have the likelihood the other
piece that we're responsible for
specifying how does the data relate to
the model
so now we're conditioning on our model
uh conditioning your model on on the
observed on the observed data and our
data can look a lot of different ways
right so our data is often normally
distributed right heights and weights of
people
any sums of other variables tend to be
normal because of something called the
central limit theorem
so what we observe x sorry i switched it
from wide x x
here could be normal with some unknown
uh mu and
and variance
that we need to estimate
uh baseball uh right so we have hitters
that try to hit the ball
uh in a certain number of tries so
we want to estimate the probability that
this uh hitter might get a a hit in the
sometime in the future so we're gonna to
use a binomial distribution to describe
that sort of data successes
out of a certain number of trials
let's say you're on a website you're
trying to estimate you know expected
numbers of visitors per month there are
likelihoods for uh estimate for
characterizing counts of things
right when that could be you know up in
the
tens or hundreds of thousands
right
and so the magic of beige is that it's
going to take those
two pieces of information what we know
before some new information and generate
something afterwards and that so that
funny little symbol in between
the two sides of the equation means
proportional to
means equal to up to uh but not
including a constant value
and so full base looks like that
and um
the the thing that makes bass hard is is
essentially the the probability of y
underneath
in the denominator of that fraction in
bayes formula that is a kind of a weird
thing probability of y probability of
the data it's actually the marginal
probability of the data so it's it's the
numerator integrated
over all of the thetas
and uh
you know i i took calculus in school i
can do integration when there's like one
variable uh i think i took a test where
i had to do twice two variables
multivariate integration is very very
hard and nearly impossible and and
particularly in models where you have
hundreds or thousands of parameters that
you have to integrate over
so it requires numerical methods in
order to do it and that's what
probabilistic programming is going to do
for us is it's going to
take that inference procedure that's
usually very complex
and tricky and uh and
kind of make it go away
but you know like i
like to do and when i teach this in a
course
it you can do it by hand for simple
problems and i think it's useful even in
a situation like this to do this
together so we'll do a simple problem by
hand and then we'll look at prime seat
uh
so let i'm gonna use again a baseball
example because i have lots of baseball
data uh so uh i'm gonna estimate so
uh for those the unfamiliar with the
sport the pitcher throws the ball the
batter's got to try to hit it
and uh it's very hard to hit a baseball
when it's thrown at you at high rate of
speed and so they strike out some of the
time so strikeout is when you take three
swings at the ball and uh you miss and
then you're you're done and then the
next batter comes up and so
if we're trying to minimize the uh
strikeout rate of a batter if we're
running a baseball team so we have a
player on the phillies name nick
castellanos he plays right field and um
back in 2019
um
he he came up to about 22 times to start
the season and he only had one strikeout
which is really low
but of course you know
22 played appearances and all that much
you'll probably have 600 of those during
the year
so we want to know what we want to know
is what's his true strikeout right
what's the underlying truth there
because you could get that by accident
um
so
the reason we can do this one by hand is
a little trick a little statistical
trick called conjugacy and for certain
data for certain models
with certain types of variables
you can do the
base formula update without having to do
any integration and in this case you can
because
uh that strikeout data remember is
binomial right it's the number how many
22 tries and he did it once so that's
binomial data
if you put a beta prior on that and we
saw the beta prior for the disease thing
right it's values between zero one we're
estimating a rate of strikeouts here we
call that a beta distribution and turns
out if you combine the two of those you
get a posterior distribution that's also
a beta so that's pretty handy right
because you can estimate that and then
maybe observe some more data and take
the posterior that's a beta distribution
and make it the prior the next time and
look at some more data and you can keep
turning the bayesian crank that way
and so this is what it looks like a
little bit of math here not too much
this is what a binomial distribution
looks like so theta is our probability
of the event y are the number of events
right and if i just look at the what i
call kernel of this distribution it's
theta that y one minus theta the n minus
y so the number of successes and the
numbers of failures and their associated
probabilities well a beta distribution
looks like this
and if you squint at those they look
really similar don't they theta to the
something one minus theta to the
something in this case the variable of
interest is theta up there the variable
of interest is y but they're the same
form so you can squish those together
and reduce it and you end up with
another beta distribution and a beta
distribution is parametrized by alpha
and beta essentially the number of prior
successes and prior failures and so it's
beta alpha plus the number of observed
successes beta alpha plus the number of
observed successes and beta plus the
number of failures and minus y
so let's do it let's do some base so
this is what one of 22 looks like
in terms of a likelihood right and it
implies you know a strikeout rate that's
below 10 percent
uh although it could be as high as you
know 30
and you know just kind of happened by
accident um we're not sure
well let's uh get a a prior for this
well how do we get a prior for this
what's our prior
what i did for a prior is i went to my
big baseball database and i pulled out
all of the batting data
over three years of of uh three seasons
of playing and i i took out all the
players with over 200 plate appearances
so lots of data
and i got their strikeout rate and in
scipy there's a big stats library in
scipy and you can just fit distributions
whichever one you want any distribution
you call
in this case beta because it's a beta
distribution dot fit it'll give you the
parameter estimates and that turns out
it's a beta 1035.
right
so
we can uh we've got the formulas to do
both and so uh the black line over there
is our prior uh the the uh
uh
or sorry that's the data the prior is
the dark blue line and then the
posterior is always going to be
somewhere between the prior and the
likelihood right
it's a little bit closer to the to the
prior in this case because there wasn't
much data and now we have kind of a
reasonable posterior estimate right
uh we didn't have to choose that prior
we could choose a different one um you
know what if we know a little bit more
about baseball is oh castellanos is a
right fielder different players in
different positions have different
characteristics so i'm just going to
take the right fielders in my data set
more restricted data set data set to use
and that turns out to be a beta 1547.
okay and that
corresponds to the red here so now we're
you know we're hedging our bets a little
bit more back towards the prior of a
higher strikeout rate because
outfielders are big heavy hitters that
strike out a lot
right which one is right
we're not sure um but the point is you
can choose your prior based on on
whatever information you have
and you really want to bring as much
information as you can to the table to
get the best estimate the goal here is
to get the right answer not to be
statistically pure right as long as you
tell people what your prior is as long
as you specify it as part of your model
you can argue later about whether or not
that was a good choice or not
okay that's the idea that's kind of your
base by hand
but
you know
your your model and your data will
quickly outstrip what you're able to do
by hand and you'll have to turn to some
software to help you out for bigger
models and here in 2022 uh we're
extremely blessed
uh with a lot of different um
choices when it comes to doing bays even
just in python these are just the ones
for doing this in python right so pi
stand and pimc
uh pyro numpyro kind of the facebook
thing tensorflow probability if you're a
google guy uh
and and others there's a whole this i
just want to give you a subset here
okay um we'll talk about here about uh
pi mc uh because i work on that project
um
so pimc mc is just for fitting bayesian
statistical models uh using a variety of
methods there are more than one method
for doing bayesian inference something
called markov chain monte carlo is
primarily what we use and i'm going to
describe describe that in a little bit
of detail later
it includes all those statistical
distributions you'll need that's kind of
one of the things that it takes a little
bit time to learn uh to kind of use
bayesian methods is learning all the
different statistical distributions and
and when and where they should be used
it leverages a package called rvs which
kind of spun out of python of prime c
years ago for doing lots of output
analysis and plotting
it's very extensible so if you find a
probability distribution that we don't
have it's easy to implement your own you
can extend even the uh
algorithms for fitting the models if
you're so disposed
and that includes things like
non-parametric bayesian methods which is
another great aspect of bayes that we
don't have time to go into today
and we just released a new version prime
c4 was released just a couple of weeks
ago we're very excited about that uh it
has uh now gpu support uh it supports
different computational backends like
jax and number
a lot more user-friendly than before and
and generally runs faster so all the
things you like to see in new versions
of software so i
encourage you to try it out we'll use it
here in our examples
okay um i'm gonna switch now to uh
uh jupiter notebook
if i can find my way around my own
computer
feel free to interrupt with questions by
the way
uh if anybody has one has them i will
i can answer them while i'm
switching
yes
distinct the question was among the
different libraries are there
differences between what each of them
has to offer um
i would say that the differences are
mainly in terms of high versus low level
um you know stan is probably the the
market leader if you like and it's it's
very it's it's it's um
a little bit lower level than pi mc
um
and it's built really just to do markov
chain monte carlo really quickly um so
and it tends to be
look a little bit more like r than
python
uh so it depends on kind of the
interfaces that you like to use um but
um you know most of the main ones you
know pyro pi torch they're they're all
going to be used and some of them have
uh place emphasis on different methods
for fitting bayesian models so numpyro
pyro are tend to be more towards the
variational inference side which is a
for bigger data sets um so
so that kind of reflects that choice as
well um but they all generally do the
same thing a lot they allow you to fit
your model at kind of a high level where
you don't need to know necessarily very
much about the fitting algorithms
and then uh generate results for you
yeah
okay
yes go ahead um
um
well there's not too much to say about
the likelihood right so it's a
likelihood is really just another
probability distribution
the only thing is is that it's it's and
we'll see this in a second it's pinned
to your observations so they don't
change
when you run the model it's kind of used
to inform the rest of the model
so
mechanistically in terms of how you
specify your model there's really no
difference between uh your likelihoods
and your priors
it's really just that the your
likelihoods have data associated with
them you can draw new values from that
distribution but they're just normal
distributions binomial distributions et
cetera
uh model selection so what part of
there's really three big steps to doing
bayesian inference one is write your
model down you know specify all your
probability distributions whichever
choice you want to make
fit the model which is what this talk is
mostly concerned with and then the third
is model checking and it's a very
important step and that's where you go
in
and you
see whether your model fits the data and
if you've made a bad choice of prior or
likelihood that should show up in kind
of bad goodness of fit tests
it's funny that you ask about the
likelihood most people are worried about
the prior you're worried about the
likelihood that's great because they're
equally important
okay so i'm going to quickly run through
how to fit some models in pi mc here
we are going to use more bait another
baseball example to motivate this um
so this is uh
hopefully my import data imports will
run
in finite time here oh
all right i'll talk while it's doing
that
makes me nervous that it's uh running
this long just to import anyway
so this is the stucky sticky stuff
incident uh so last year uh baseball
started cracking down on pitchers
putting stuff on their baseballs and why
would they do that
um well
pitchers try to get a good grip on their
ball on the ball and uh and spin it so
that it'll create general generate some
movement and movement makes it harder to
hit it's a way that's been doing this in
way as far back as baseball goes which
is well over 100 years uh putting stuff
like pine tar
and uh mixtures of uh of rosin and
sunscreen anything to make it kind of
tacky and sticky
and uh
this caused a lot more strikeouts which
aren't as fun for spectators to watch
and so even though the rule was kind of
in the rule books they started cracking
down in kind of the middle of last year
and you'd get you know a 10-game
suspension and a fine and things like
that
and um you know just to give you an idea
uh this is what a this is why they do it
so this is one of our pictures erin nola
throwing a curveball and you'll see
right at the end it kind of dips and
it's because he spins the ball really
quickly and
makes it really hard to hit
so they started cracking down you know
very invasive uh checks unbuckling their
belts
checking the insides of their gloves uh
nobody was very happy about this
and um
and so what we're gonna try to do here
is try to estimate whether or not the
sticky stuff crackdown had an effect on
the spin rates of baseball so we
we collect a ton of data now major
league baseball does
every game generates six to seven
terabytes of data
because they monitor all the players on
the field the ball the movement of the
ball uh and it's actually all available
for free on the
mlb advanced media website um statcast
website and so i i downloaded um
all of the data from 2021 the year where
they cracked down
and looked at their spin rates so this
is what the data looks like
um
we can plot it so here's the spin rates
by date
a little gap in the middle as they take
a break in july to do the all-star game
so there's no games for a little bit
under a week but otherwise continue it
these are all the pitches and the spin
rates on each so on average there's
about the 2500 rpm that's the spin rate
of the ball with lots of variation
and so what we're interested in knowing
here is
is there a change
during the season in spin rate due to
the crackdown trying to avoid getting
suspended
um and does that
change point uh correspond to when the
crackdown happened which was
uh
let me say here
june 3rd is when the
information kind of leaked out that they
were going to crack down
so let's build a model for this what is
the model going to look like here i'm
going to
extract some data all i need is the date
and the spin rate so that's what these
two lines is doing
and so the model i'm going to use here
is a change point model
um
it's a relatively simple model just to
demonstrate how to use prime c
and so the idea here is that really the
simplest possible model is to have a
constant spent mean spin rate across the
league and at some point there'd be a
change due to this change in policy so
there'd be an early and a late spin rate
so what we statisticians would call a
piecewise constant model right two
pieces
and so
1 and mu 2 are the two rates tau is
going to be our change point and the
tricky part here is that tau's not known
i mean we have a guess at what it was if
our hypothesis is true but we really
don't know what it is and and that's the
nice thing in bayes is that anything you
don't know you just put a probability
distribution around it and you estimate
it you include it in your model and so
that's what we're going to do here
so
two muse and a tau are our variables and
then we'll have two likelihoods and
these are going to be normally
distributed distributed
with the two means and then some common
sigma maybe the variance changed
afterwards as well we're just doing a
simple i'm not saying this is a good
model this is just a simple model and
and somewhat reasonable uh given what
we're trying to do
okay so let's step through building this
in prime c so
we're
really there are two different
types of objects in a bayesian model
stochastic and deterministic variables
so mu1 2 the means and the change point
tau are all random variables we don't
know what they are oh and sigma the kind
of noise distribution of noise around
the mean
um
so there are they arise from a physical
random process
that
sorry they're random in the sense that
we don't know them so that we don't
think that the underlying mean
necessarily is changing except in a way
that we include in our model
but we're using probability
distributions to characterize our
information state about that variable
all right so it's an epistemic
randomness here not necessarily a one
that's stochastic
and it's representing our uncertainty
about these values
there are other objects that are
deterministic so given in a given year
the rate
uh is completely determined by mu and
mu1 and mu2 and tau right if it's on one
side of tau or the other
um so the vector of rates for every day
of baseball is going to be deterministic
given those random variables right so we
have stochastic things and deterministic
things
all right so
um here's the rest of our what choices
are we going to give for our probability
distributions well our means are going
to be normal with mean 2500 because that
was i peaked at the mean there um and
then a you know a standard deviation of
100 which is a variance of 10 000. so
way bigger than we need uh
tau i'll just say uniform between zero
and t being the last day of the season
and then a half normal distribution for
cigna it's half normal because variances
have to be positive right you can't have
negative variance so we just chop the
negative side off of the normal
distribution
in prime c it looks like this
so
a couple of things to note here
the with statement we use a with
statement which
in python is a context manager and
context managers generally are used for
things like network connections
file opening and closing and it kind of
manages all that for you
here we're going to use it to open and
close a model and add variables to it so
it's a nice little trick that makes
models easy to specify
so we're going to create a model object
which is really just a big container for
our variables and how they're related to
one another we're going to call it spin
rate model
and then here are our two of our priors
so here's mu
and mu here has shape of two because
there's the early and the late
and then there's the uniform
distribution
right with a lower and an upper bound
that i'm using just you know the first
and the last day of the season which
i've encoded as integers from zero to
big t
does that make sense
okay notice each distribution has a name
it's got a label essentially and it's
been added added to the model okay
and in fact
you can't even specify you can't even
use these
random variables outside of a model if i
just say i want a normal called x with
mean mu 0 and sigma 10 and i try to run
it i get an error i get an index error
but if you scroll down to the bottom it
says no model on context stack which is
needed to instantiate distributions
okay so the
it's got a lot of um overhead associated
with it that's that's used for
integrating that distribution into the
model
and under the hood
um
oops
oh i changed the names of these things
so
change this to mu
under the hood
uh all of these variables are things
called tensor variables inside the asara
library asara is the um essentially the
back end for pymc that does all of the
heavy lifting uh
particularly building the kind of model
graph
it was it is based on thiano which is a
now extinct
deep learning library
uh and we thanks to the efforts of
brandon willard and others in the asara
team basically co-opted that
package uh that library and and turned
it essentially into a probabilistic
programming engine uh
that allows us to compile it to
different backends so you're going to
see a lot of mention of asara that's
really just kind of the back end of
pimc okay
all the distributions that you're seeing
here are based on our subclasses of a
distribution superclass
in particular the continuous subclass
and so every distribution really all it
needs to have is a
method for returning the log probability
that's what we use to fit the model
optionally a random method for drawing
new random values doesn't have to have
that but if you want to sample from your
model uh you'll want to include that as
well so if you're implementing your own
distributions that's roughly how it how
it looks
um so for any of these variables for
example tau we can pass it at you know a
value of five and and uh get the uh log
probability back right so that's the log
probability of of a five you know day
five of the uh
season essentially
similarly random is in
you use that via the draw function
right so we're going to draw five values
of mu remember mu is of size two there's
two means so it's drawing five sets of
two in this case right
if you do wanna use
our
statistical distributions outside of a
pi mc model you can do that there's a
class method called dist that just pulls
out the statistical distribution so here
i created a normal called x of size 1000
and then i
generated a histogram of that right so
you can use them outside of prime c
you've just got to
extract it in the appropriate way
and prime c has a ton of distributions
there's the whole list
right so chances are what you need is in
here and if it isn't i've just showed
you how to essentially how to do it okay
uh every distribution has a shape
remember mu is of size two so there's
this is a univariate distribution but
it's kind of a batch of two of them
right it's not a multivariate normal
although it could be
but you can have kind of batches of
distributions like this okay
let's keep going here so
the nice thing about the
context manager is that you can you know
add some variables close it up crack it
open again add a few more so we're going
to add sigma here because we had one
more random variable this is our
our observation noise essentially
and in the models keeping track of
what's in it and and you know all the
details so there's those are the
variables we've added so far
um
and uh prime c is doing a lot of stuff
under the hood for you here um
you know um for example when you specify
a half normal distribution as i said
before it's constrained to be positive
but when we're doing s model estimation
and we're doing mcmc sampling
we don't want to have to worry about
that lower bound of zero and so
everything under the hood gets
transformed to the real line so in this
case we're going to log transform it
uh so you know you pass a negative 1 to
this
i don't know why this is taking so long
uh you get it's undefined uh it's not
undefined at in negative values and if
you look under the hood here
you'll see that uh the name implies that
something's happened sigma underscore
log so it's been log transformed
um
but you don't have to worry about that
they inverse transform it when you
get the results of the model so you
don't have to it's really just something
that's convenient for for computation
all right now deterministic variables so
deterministic variable again is is
anything that's completely determined by
the value of its parents so our vector
of rates
across the season is completely
determined by mu and tau and so this is
it here it's a little switch statement
when tau is greater than
day in so
past the
the switch point
uh
it's mu zero sorry if tau is the other
way around if tau is greater than d n so
it's the first half of the season uh
it's mu zero otherwise it's mu one
okay and notice here that um i didn't
give this a name like i did with the
other things you remember is normal mu
and then uniform tau um this is kind of
an anonymous thing here with no name
associated with it because this is sort
of an intermediate calculation i'm not
really interested in this vector of
copied values essentially and so this
in this sense they'll kind of be thrown
away at the end of the model fitting
exercise
if you want to
specify something as
well that's some bad color choices here
if you want to specify something as
um uh if you want to make it persist in
the model and summarize it at the end
you have to wrap it in a pimc
deterministic object and then you give
it a name
okay so now this will exist in the trace
that you get out the other end otherwise
you can just leave it anonymously
and of course the shape on this is going
to be bigger
because we are
so there's one for every pitch that's
thrown here 7791
all right last step the likelihood
so as i said before there's really no
difference between stochastic and
observed variables in the model one just
has data associated with it the others
don't and so the way that you do that in
prime c
is you pass the data
to the distribution using the observed
argument here so spin rate is the vector
of spin rates for every pitch otherwise
it's just a regular normal distribution
and so mu is r so it's our vector of
rates
and then sigma is the observation noise
okay and you can always see what your
likelihoods are oops haven't haven't run
the cell yet there it is okay you can
always check what it is looking at
observed rvs
and then uh another step that's useful
at the end is to actually look at your
model
and so you can generate a graph
a picture of the graph using graphviz
um this is always good right if you're
building more complex models i often do
this and i'll have like a node floating
around unattached to anything and that
would cause problems so just make sure
that your model's all connected the way
you you think it should be
okay and then now uh we run this and all
we have to do is call sample
all right
um and i anticipate this to take longer
than it should because something's weird
with my computer today
uh so this is the uh the magic inference
button this is a phrase coined by thomas
vicki who's here in this uh
meeting he allowed me to say he's
trademarked it uh but he let me say it
uh
and so well this is the thing i didn't
give it any arguments just to show you
how easy it can be so there are a lot of
um
uh defaults implied here and we'll go
into that in the kind of the next
section and so it will run this uh in
just a few seconds
yeah should take way less time than this
sorry about that
it took about two seconds the other day
um so anyway you'll see what it says
here auto assigning nut sampler we don't
know what that is yet initializing nuts
using something and then multi-process
sampling it's going to sample four
chains
and it shows you the random variables
that it's estimating and then it's it's
running
is about 10 times as long as it usually
takes okay and then we can generate
plots of things so
one we're interested in here is tau so
the mean of tau is 68 although it's got
a weird bimodal thing it's maybe a
little uncertain about where that is the
mean is 68 and if you look at
where in the calendar 68 is
it's june the 8th which is less than a
week
after they changed the regulation so
there's a little bit of evidence here of
change spin rates changing okay
all right
next i'm going to dig into a little bit
more into um
mcmc so i need to
un-mirror my monitor
yes please ask a question while
oh yeah yeah we're definitely interested
in how big it is let me see
um
so oh you can't see this anymore um
mu naught was 2539
and uh mu one was 2442 so about a
hundred rpms less
which can make the difference
it's a game of fine margins
uh
all right
go for it
uh well once once it's compiled it's
kind of out of prime c's hands so the so
the the jax is so it compiles to c which
is what thiano gave us before
jax and then uh a little bit of number
at the moment and so potentially more
than that and all it's doing is
compiling it for the mcmc computation so
all the features
aren't really relevant it's just doing
the gradient calculation and all the
kind of mcmc steps
all right so we're going to talk about
mcmc this is the um
so the main challenge in doing fitting
bayesian models resides in actually
calculating the joint posterior
distribution over all of the models
right and so so this was the hard piece
right integration is hard
now if i was teaching my course here at
vanderbilt i would spend like two weeks
going through
from the basic this is kind of ranked in
order of complexity
all the different ways you can
approximate a posterior distribution
from simple but
probably
inadequate to getting closer and closer
to something that's usable
right we're going to skip ahead
to the workhorse this is kind of the de
facto standard method now for fitting
bayesian models so mcmc stands for
markov chain monte carlo
so two pieces to that monte carlo and
markov chain
so it's going to simulate a markov chain
so martin carlos just a fancy word for
simulation using a random number
generator
and
we're going to simulate a markov chain
where
the function of interest our posterior
distribution is its unique invariant
stationary distribution lots of jargon
there
first jargon we're going to break here
is what a markov chain is
so
markov chain is something called a
stochastic process which is just jargon
for a indexed set of random variables so
it's typically indexed by t because it's
often temporal but doesn't have to be
and it's markovian so the markovian
condition is
it's all it says is that the probability
of some variable
its value in the next time step
given its current value
the last value all the way back to its
initial value
is the same as the probability of its
next value given just its current value
so essentially the history doesn't
matter other than right now right these
are pretty common like we play monopoly
that's a markov chain right
you landing in park place and the next
turn only
is only determined by the fact that
you're i don't know on reading railway
and not that you were in jail three
turns ago or anything like that the
current state matters the past doesn't
matter so it's kind of mild
non-independence if you want to think of
it that way
it's very hard to estimate bayesian
models by drawing independent samples so
what we resort to are dependent samples
and we can get the same sort of result
it can't just be any markov chain that
we simulate here though it's got to be a
special one the specialness comes from a
property called the detailed balance
equation we want a markov chain that
obeys this property
and this has to do with balancing
movement to and from different states
okay
glossing over lots of complexity here
but i just wanted to give you a little
bit of intuition about what's going on
here if it obeys this property
then
pi is the limiting distribution of the
chain i.e the posterior distribution so
pi pi of y pi of x is going to be our
posterior distribution so anytime you
see a new mcmc algorithm pop up
the paper will show that it's reversible
that's kind of the pro the thing that
you have to prove before anybody
believes you
the very simplest mcmc out so there's no
such thing as mcmc as an algorithm it's
a class of algorithm right it's like
bird there's no birds called a bird
they've all got species associated with
them same thing here
so one of the simplest ones is the
metropolis algorithm and it's really
easy
a couple steps here that last one should
be a four not a one don't know why that
happened so four steps
all right you initialize all the
parameters of your model to arbitrary
values and then you have another
distribution that's easy to sample with
from and you draw potential new values
for that distribution
you evaluate whether it's good or not
and whether it's good or not depends on
the ratio of the posterior log posterior
distribution under the new values theta
prime over its current values
okay you can't calc you can't you don't
really know what this posterior
distribution is but you can always
remember every variable has a log p in
prime c you can always calculate the log
probability for any value so you can
always do this
you have this acceptance probability if
that probability is higher than that one
you accept it all the time and if you
don't you accept it probabilistically
you draw a uniform random variable and
you kind of flip a coin so you sometimes
accept
bad values right it's part of this
reversibility thing you don't just want
to find the peak of the distribution you
want to find the whole thing
and so metropolis sampling kind of looks
like this
all right so it's proposing values
sometimes accepting them
i can't remember who i stole this from
it was probably thomas did i steal this
from you thomas
no okay then i did it this is mine um
and but notice it's getting stuck here
so this is a complex problem this is
actually a thousand dimensional
multivariate normal so it's not complex
sorry it's very simple it's just large
right
it's a big geometry and so it's kind of
getting stuck it's not doing a very good
job here
interesting
well the reason it's getting stuck is
it's not very good
metropolis algorithm is not very good
it's very easy to implement it's very
general
but it doesn't do well for larger models
and the reason is is that
as
models get big the volume in terms of
the space of the parameter space
grows exponentially so that exponential
line is the volume the probability
or the density
the probability density function is
there so as you move away
uh from the mode the volume gets very
big
and the density doesn't so most of the
probability is actually away from the
mode
and so it's really easy to get stuck in
areas of low probability
this area of high probability it's hard
to see there is shaded it's called the
typical set and that's what we want to
do
is estimate the typical set
and to do that we need a better
algorithm and the better algorithm is
something called hamiltonian monte carlo
hamiltonian monte carlo is yet another
mcmc algorithm but this one uses more
information about your model
specifically it uses gradient
information
so metropolis we were doing a random
walk right we were randomly drawing a
new value and as you might
sort of intuitively that's not very
efficient right just random values
are they going to be good or not
probably not
but if we use information about the
gradient we can get essentially better
suggested values and do a better job and
so what this does is it simulates kind
of a physical analogy of a particle
moving you think about a skateboarder in
a skate park right
and you kind of you know push your
skateboarder into the park and what is
what does she do she kind of rolls
around following the
topology of the park right or or a
marble in a salad bowl or something like
that right goes up and down and so we do
this to explore the posterior
distribution
and so we add an auxiliary variable
to simulate essentially
well position and momentum or kinetic
energy and potential energy right
and and in kind of discrete time
discretized time
okay and so it requires the gradient and
so derivatives derivatives are easy
nowadays on computers integration is
hard just
derivatives are easy
particularly when you have a package
like thiano or asara or tensorflow or
pi torch whatever they all give you
these things for free now so we
calculate essentially the changes in
position and the changes in momentum
and use that to monitor uh where the
where to go in terms of characterizing
the typical set of the distribution so
you take all of these little leap frog
steps you're kind of following the
contours of the posterior distribution
you stop you take a value and then you
you know flick the particle in a
different random direction
and so the algorithm is even even easier
than metropolis
sample a new velocity from univariate
gaussian i.e your initial
energy perform a certain number of
leapfrog steps to get a new state
because you're simulating you're using
it's a continuous system but you're
using discrete steps to approximate it
and then you do an accept reject move
because you're doing this approximation
at the end and you accept it or not
and hamiltonian mc looks like this
boom
and it can even do more complicated
things than multivariate normals it can
you know be those weird banana shaped
distributions with a huge ridge on it or
whatever
okay
in fact that logo at the very beginning
one of our developers colin
uh carol did it's simulating the pimc
logo so it can be super complex stuff
okay
and then i'll skip right to the punch
line is that you know
when you saw
remember when i ran sample it said
initializing nuts
well nuts is a
particular uh tuned auto-tuning version
of hamiltonian monte carlo called the no
u-turn sampler it's no u-turn because
when you know when you do that
moving around the space what happens
when you go up a hill and you reach the
top of the hill
you roll backwards again and you want to
stop before you do that u-turn because
you're just you know recalculating the
same values over and over again so the
no u-turn sample sampler is the state of
the art
and this is why we use it so this is the
same
ten thousand dimensional or
thousand-dimensional multi-very normal
just marginal two variables from that
and that's what metropolis does another
mcmc sampler that nobody uses anymore
and that's what nut nuts does relative
to just independent draws right so
that's what we want to do and that's why
we use nuts
okay that's your you know this this
few minutes of talk would have taken
like a week
in my class so we've glossed over a lot
of stuff but um hopefully that gives you
a little bit of of intuition
is there a question while i'm
moving back over
yes
you don't and that's why you want a auto
tuning
algorithm that's what nuts does is it it
it optimizes the number of leapfrog
steps it depends on the model
right simpler models
you wanna you wanna do as few as
possible the goal isn't to perfectly
follow the path it's to get a good point
and
as you can imagine the more steps you
have to take the more computationally
intensive it is so you want to take as
few as possible and so the nuts
algorithm estimates the optimal number
for you yeah good question
i wish i could uh
mirror this thing again ah there we go
all right
let's see it's 11 54. i started out i
have a half an hour still is that right
cool
we may even have time for questions
although we're taking questions during
it so
any any more questions by the way since
we're
on schedule
sorry i didn't understand that sorry can
you repeat it again
yes what's your habit
what is it um
it's determined automatically so so
there's two things there's two
components so the position is your
actual posterior distribution that
you're interested in
and the momentum is the auxiliary
variable that you're giving with this
with the energy so so your model your
posterior distribution is the position
so it's not using kinetic energy
potential energy it's using position and
momentum
and so the momentum's auxiliary it gets
thrown away and you keep the position
all right let's dig into this a little
bit here
um so i'm gonna use another sports
example but i'll at least use a sport
that most of you are probably familiar
with
uh so six nations rugby
uh it's the prim the premier european uh
rugby competition those are the only six
countries that play rugby i guess
you could argue whether italy plays it
or not but they participate
and um so we're gonna this example's on
a version of this is on our website as
one of the examples
so what we're doing is we're taking
historical rugby data to try to predict
the outcome of the next tournament right
and you know it's probably not valid
because we're using you know results
from 2014
probably entirely different players on
all of these teams by now but forget
that for the moment and so we're going
to take a whole bunch of historical
scores and try to predict new scores i'm
going to do that by estimating latent
variables which is what bayesian
inference is good for and the latent
variables will be the strengths the
underlying
unobserved strengths of these teams
in terms of scoring and preventing uh
points from being scored
right
so this is all the data a home score and
an away score for every game going back
to 2014.
so our model here will look a little
different so again you got to think
about our unknown variables and our
likelihoods and so forth uh let's in
this case start with the likelihood work
backwards uh so scoring points they're
discrete you can't score half points you
can't score negative points so a poisson
is a reasonable approach here poisson
distribution is a counting distribution
has to be positive the mean and the
variance are equal so as as the numbers
get larger the variance gets larger
reasonable choice for counting things
that don't have an upper bound like a
binomial does
okay so we're gonna have two poissons
here
home score and away score
your score and your opponent's score
right so two poisson means and then the
means in turn will be determined by
uh a log linear equation the reason it's
going to be log linear is because the
poisson mean has to be positive
and the way to constrain that is to make
it inverse log inverse log right so
exponential
uh of that
and so there'll be two pieces alpha and
delta uh
attack and defense which is why i chose
those so they attack so for the away
team
it'll be the uh the
alpha
uh
i think i have that backwards it should
be the alpha yeah it should be the alpha
of of the away team
and the delta the defense of the home
team oh no sorry this backward this is
the home sorry home is going to be the
alpha of the home team and the defense
of the away team and then ada is a a
factor for home home field advantage
right you play better at home because
all the fans are yelling for you and you
sleep in your own bed at night and stuff
like that
uh so it's some some unknown factor all
right and then for the uh
what we're going to do is transform
those so that they're centered on the
mean so that centered on the kind of
like we did for the baseball we center
out on the mean so this is going to be
the mean score of a rugby match and then
these are so that they all add up to
zero these are going to be transformed
so they're a little easier to interpret
okay oh and then for the away team it's
exactly the same but there's no ada
right and then uh the alphas and deltas
are reversed so it's the alpha of the
away team and the delta of the home team
i hope that's clear
well they can't be both oh i see yeah
then you yeah you could do it right you
just leave the ada off of both of them
if they're playing like in the united
states or something right
i don't think that happens in six
nations though so we don't have to worry
about it
all right
i'm just going to explain this uh it's
just a
pandas factorizes my favorite pandas
function it essentially does what
scikit-learn's label encoder does so it
takes a list of team names here
and it turns them into integers from
zero to the number of teams so it's
gonna
it's gonna turn it into zero through
five in this case
right
and uh so one of the newer features of
pymc it's actually not a pime c4 thing
it was available in later versions of
prime c3 is that you can
specify the size of your
variables in your model using labeled
arrays rather than just integers so i'm
going to take my list of teams and use
them as the coordinates and then when i
print out the results and whatever it
will have the name of you know england
whales etc on them and so i put that in
a dictionary
and i pass that to the model
as the chords argument
all right and
another thing that i'm going to do
that's relatively new in pi mc is i'm
going to make my data mutable what does
that mean mutable means i can change my
data
why would i want to change my data
well i'll fit my model using you know as
we do in machine learning we fit our
model using fitting data and then i want
to use this model right i want to say
okay now that i fit my model i want to
see what wales and england do
next week when they play in wales and so
i'll
i'll change the data and then without
having to rerun the model
it'll it'll generate predictions for me
right so i have this thing called
mutable data so i'm going to change the
home and away teams later on
so what it's really doing is adding it
as a node in the graph
as symbolic node and then when it's
symbolic i can feed whatever
values that i want into them
okay
so next step priors what are my priors
going to be
they're all going to be normal right
we're dealing with
uh
rates
sorry
not rates but actually factors that have
been transformed to the real line so
my home field advantage ada is just
going to be normal with mu 1 sigma 1.
those seem small but this is on the logs
or inverse log scale so
they get blown up when you call
exponential on them so that's actually
quite diffuse and then mu
so you know exponential of 3 is about
17 or 20 or something like that and so
that's a reasonable
approximate mean for what a population
an average score is going to be
and then
the alphas and deltas and now notice i i
didn't call shape now i called dims and
i just passed the list of the dictionary
of teams to that and so it'll make sure
that it's got one for each team on
attack and defense
go ahead um
um it shouldn't really be science it
should be pr it should be whatever so
you could give them uninformative priors
there's a thing in here called a flat
prior that's just
no district it's not even a real
distribution
you really want to add as much
domain expertise as you can the only
domain i don't know anything about rugby
i work in baseball so
only information i know is what the
scores kind of tend to be like you can't
get scores of a million and you can't
they don't tend to be like one or zero
so i i actually just peeked at the
population and put the population mean
in here and that's a valid thing to do
here because one way of thinking about
your prior is actually the underlying
population that you're trying to infer
right like that baseball player right i
used kind of the population of all
baseball players that's a great prior
because you know what that is you don't
know where your player is in that but
mine has got to be in there somewhere or
most likely you want to allow for it to
possibly be the greatest baseball player
ever but that's not likely to be the
case unless there's lots of data to
support it yeah
oh what i do here
variable name ada already exists well no
it doesn't
oh i hit it twice didn't i
i must have hit it twice all right
okay deterministic so here's my
transformation so a t dot mean that's
asara tensor
so you try to use asara functions here
when you can it's got most of what numpy
has all the important ones anyway so
there's alpha star and delta star and
then my model for home and away just
like i wrote above mu plus eta plus
alpha plus delta for home
same for a way except no ada
likelihoods remember the only difference
here is we have observed and so we're
passing rugby data home score the first
one rugby data away score for the second
one
and
i always like to strip out the panda
stuff and use the values in principle it
works with
pandas but sometimes i get unexpected
things going on
and again we're going to look at our
model again
and it's bigger it's more complex now
even this simple model and just for
convenience i'm going to wrap this all
the whole model
in a function so i can just create a new
model whenever i need to because i'm
going to intentionally do bad things
with this model
um sorry the colors are so bad here
hold on
i'm gonna go back to my
is that easier to see
uh so
remember i ran sample with no arguments
before and everybody freaked out uh
because there's a whole bunch of
defaults here and they're usually
reasonable but it's always good to know
what you can change and there's even
more than this but these are the ones
you'd change more often
right so you want to know how many draws
do you need
thousands of good that's how many draws
after the model's finished tuning
usually only for hamiltonian monte carlo
usually a thousand or so is good enough
assuming the model is converged tuning
for small models thousands also pretty
good i like to do two by default
whatever
you will we'll see in a minute
how you know whether you need more or
not
a lot of these things get auto assigned
so the step means the mcmc algorithm the
step method the way
and so it knows how to do a step of a
particular algorithm it'll assign them
automatically uh unless you want to
override it i'll show you how to do that
in just a second you can
specify initial values if you want to
uh how many chains you want to you want
to sample from all of these things i'll
go through some of these here in a
second
so assigning a sampling algorithm
usually you want to let it do this
itself unless you have a good reason to
override it but you can
so i can instantiate a metropolis
algorithm and pass it and it'll do
metropolis sampling but we saw that
metropolis algorithm isn't very good so
you wouldn't want to do this most of the
time
uh the only way they so underneath under
the hood there um every um distributions
has a uh a competence associated or
every algorithm has a competence
associated with it that says i'm good at
continuous variables i'm good at
discrete variables don't use me here
things like that and so it goes through
when it auto-assigns and determines the
best the ones with the highest
competence score and assigns it so in
general continuous variables get the nut
sampler
but
those variables have to be continuous
right because it uses gradient
information you can't take gradients of
discrete things so if it's discrete you
get metropolis
sorry
and then binary gets a binary metropolis
where you can only assign zeros and ones
okay that's generally it but there are
other samplers that are available to you
initial values you can pass your own
otherwise it will use the mean or the
mode
or the median depending on which
distribution
you can sample to get it
again most of the time here unless you
have a tricky model that it can be
helpful to specify an initial value
you can override it by passing them here
so let's do
a simple
thing here
500 draws with no tuning using
metropolis with an initializing ada to
be negative one
and i'm just doing this
oh god
any questions while it's sampling this
really simple model for a short period
of time yes
to monitor the
data update the model with new data uh
oh yeah uh well you can predict with the
model with new data
um
but if you've got new data that you want
to use to fit the model you've got to
refit it i mean if you want to be a
really awesome bayesian you really want
to like take your posteriors from the
last one and use it in the prior but
that's harder to do than you think right
because you'll get a sometimes a weird
posterior distribution and how do you
turn that into a prior if it's done a
good job all your posteriors are going
to be multivariate normal and you can
just make them multivariate normal so
you could do that but you kind of
manually have to do that yeah all right
it finished finally um
actually it only took one set so it's
having a problem compiling i guess for
some reason
okay
and if we look at ada here it doesn't
look very good so this is a trace plot
from rvs that's those are supposed to be
histograms over there they don't look
very good
and then this is the trace so this is
the sequence of 500 values and i didn't
do any tuning on here and i used a
crappy algorithm so this is what we
expect right so they all started at
negative one and they popped up
but they're not really in the same
region and there's four chains here so
there's four different lines
so it doesn't look very good
all right let's do it for real now
and hopefully this doesn't take very
long
so i'm going to do this is really the
defaults i could have just
called sample without any arguments here
here we go so it's auto assigning blah
blah
yeah this is a bad demo sorry it usually
runs a lot faster
i'm gonna i'm gonna run everything below
here just to speed things up
okay and look ooh you got some warnings
here the acceptance probability does not
match the target blah blah blah there
are five divergences after tuning blah
blah blah okay we'll see what those are
later so we try to warn you when things
go wrong
as best we can
pardon me
uh should be close to 0.8 and it's not
so it's supposed to be 0.8 yeah
don't worry i'll get back i'll get to it
but here we see
estimates
of alpha this is the attacking strength
and so
england's the best
as they are at everything
right
so and and so there are four chains and
they all look the same which should
inspire confidence right they all
started and they all ended up at the
same place
in each of these so they look pretty
good
the countries are where we expect them
to be
and then defense so it's flipped around
now so italy is the worst and now
island's the best
so these
comport to um what we expect
muanida so this is a posterior plot so
this gives you
um a uh
hdi which is a probability interval so
there's a 94 probability the two values
between those two points
and then it's distribution so eta is
0.24 mu is 2.8 remember these are on the
log scale so if we convert these 2.8 is
about 16 points
2.8 plus 2.24 is about
21 points so there's a home field
advantage of four and a half points
which
i guess is reasonable in american
football it's like three points i think
for a home field most of the time and it
probably varies by country too right
depending on where you are
these samples are stored used in a
modified x-ray backend
so labeled
arrays which is pretty nice
and that's a class inside of the rvs
package again so you can see our
posterior distribution has you know for
each chain all of the draws for each of
the teams they're labeled with names so
they're really easy to use
so you've got your posterior in there
your log likelihood sample stats for
things like well we'll look at what some
of these are in a second
and even a copy of the data in here so
inference data is one of the relatively
recent innovations of pymc that makes
things a lot easier
uh parallel sampling you really want to
do more than one chain uh for one thing
you've you know all our computers here
have probably at least four cores if not
eight and um you can you know it's this
is all embarrassingly parallel every
chain can be sampled independently of
one another so there's no reason not to
so by default it takes the half of the
number of cores you have available
uh so i got four automatically without
telling it anything in this example i i
picked six chains and using four cores
so it did it
you know
partially parallel and so you end up
with you know n times c chains here so
this was for alpha so there's six of
them so it's six by one hundred by six
is the size
and you you know you typically wanna
combine all of these together uh at the
end
so kind of the last topic we have about
15 minutes left
is an important piece we referred to it
earlier on model checking is very
important
you don't you can get reasonable looking
results and it just could be complete
nonsense and it's hard to tell sometimes
whether it is there's two components to
model checking convergence diagnostics
at least for mcmc did mcmc actually work
right mcmc can work and your model may
or may not be good but you at least want
to make sure mcmc works before you
proceed
and given that mcmc worked okay
what is the fit of the model like how
does it
does it make any sense does it
correspond to what the data
suggests
all of those things
so how do we do this stuff convergence
diagnostics the easiest thing is to gaze
at the trace just look at it
that's what a trace looks like so this
is one run i call this bad trace because
i
did bad things with it
uh what did i do i only tuned it for 10
iterations which was not very good and
you can see
you know this is for two chains they
don't they don't correspond very well
um you know this kind of gets stuck in
places from time to time so it needs to
be tuned a little bit more
attuned tune one you want to look for
this sort of fuzzy caterpillar kind of
thing going on over here right they
remember what we needed what we're
trying to look for here a stationary
uh homogeneous markov chain means it's
not you know the chain isn't moving
around the mean is staying relatively
constant the variance is staying
relatively constant that sort of thing
this is getting a little closer but it's
not even quite there yet
remember we saw a warning about
divergences in fact this is exactly the
warning i pasted it down here there were
five divergences after tuning increased
target accept or re-parametrize we try
to suggest what to do to resolve
problems where we can a divergence is
when this hamilt remember hamilton monte
carlo was doing the leapfrog steps and
then sampling leapfrog steps and the
leapfrog steps we're trying to trace
this continuous hamiltonian system as
best it can well sometimes it does a
poor job of it so here are a couple
where it's done a good job so the true
distribution here is the this cone
of red and yellow and so here it's
wandering around nicely there it's not
doing too bad and this one it got
launched into space over here and it
diverts way off in a low probability
region that would be a divergence
you don't need to freak out if this
happens unless it happens a lot so we
only had five in this case over a
thousand samples i wouldn't worry about
that
setting a higher target acceptance is
one way of resolving this and so what
that will do
it will increase the number of baby
steps that it has to take
and so
so that uh the acceptance rate
so 0.8 is the default it's a relatively
good default if you're having trouble
boost it to 0.9 or 0.95 or 0.99 even
it'll take longer to run but you'll
you'll get fewer divergences
even better re-parameterize your model
it's sometimes a sign that your model is
a little bit wonky
so um and there i won't go into what
that means here but re-parameterization
often works too
um with these um
gradient-based samplers there's some
information that you can get from those
because of the energy remember we're
tracking
energy here momentum and so forth
and uh based on on the estimates of the
energy at each step relative to the
overall energy
of the sampling
you can estimate how well
the algorithm has been been exploring
the posterior distribution and it's
based on this notion of a bayesian
fraction of missing information that
again i will
gloss over a little bit you want it to
be close to one
and so
i don't know those look close to one to
me there's no real good cut off but the
easiest way to deal with this is to do
an energy plot
so this plots the the transition energy
transitions at each step versus the
overall marginal energy after fitting
and you want them to sort of overlap
like they do here
um bad ones look like that
where the marginal energy distribution
is way wider
and so it's saying that the transition
energy just isn't covering everything
okay so that's a bad sign i sometimes
get like bimodal ones where there's two
blue bumps
on either side that's a bad sign too
uh one other that's worth noting is
something called used to be the called
the gelman-rubin statistic now it's
called r hat or the potential scale
reduction this is essentially an
analysis of variance of the traces if
you know it an analysis of variances
it's comparing the variation within
a particular chain to the variance
between chains and if they're the same
they should be similar to one another if
your chains are in different spots the
between variance is wider than the
within right so that's kind of what an
anova does
um and those should also be and so it's
so as
um
it converges on the overall variance the
r hat will get close to one so all you
have to know is you want your r heights
close to one so if you call rvs.summary
you get a nice summary table
and your r hats will be over here and
look they're all really close to one so
we're happy about these
so convergence diagnostics done
we've got a yes
the burn-in yeah we call it apparently
we're not supposed to call it burn-in
anymore we're supposed to call it tuning
so it's tuning for a tune for a thousand
and that's again uh i usually pick 2000
except for a really simple model
back in the bad days of metropolis you'd
do like a hundred thousand
uh so it's it's much better now
but you'll know if you need more you'll
you'll have signs of lack of convergence
yeah in some cases you just need to run
it longer that's that's all so goodness
of fit last topic
goodness of fit um
you wanna you want this is essentially a
calibration check for your model
and um
the best way to do this sort of thing is
to compare
the output from your model
to the data that was used to fit the
model
and really your
if you draw a whole bunch of samples
from your model
your data should just look like another
draw from that model otherwise you can't
really claim that this is the data
generating model which is what you want
the nice thing is is that bayes gives
you an automatic way of doing this
and this is called the posterior
predictive distribution and this is it
here
so f of theta given y is just our
posterior remember
and then
p of y tilde given theta p tilde are new
values
right things we're going to sample from
the data given theta and that theta has
already been conditioned on y
um this is the predictive distribution
this is just our likelihood we're
drawing values from our likelihood
remember a lot of likelihood is y given
theta as well
so we're including the residual
uncertainty in our parameters and the
stochastic sampling uncertainty of just
you know drawing from a binomial
distribution
and then you integrate over theta which
sounds intimidating because
integration's hard but you get this for
free already because you fit your model
using mcmc so we don't have to worry
about it so we can get this all we have
to do is sample from our
after fitting our data our model sample
from our likelihoods and so we have a
method for doing that in prime c it's
called sample posterior predictive
and it's gonna this argument here will
just stick it back onto the trace
sorry for the functional programmers out
there but it's just going to add it to
that trace
silently without telling you and so
we'll have a thing in here called
posterior predictive now
and we can do plots so there's rvs has
plot ppc and these are cumulative
distributions of
draws from the model which are blue
and their mean is
a dashed yellow line and the data is a
black line which is kind of hard to see
here but
but that's a good sign too right if you
can't even see your data that's a good
sign if it was out here
going over here we'd be worried right
so these are
good
checks the observed data looks like
draws from the posterior distribution
oh got 10 minutes left i lied i had one
more topic making predictions
uh because i mentioned this before right
um
i can swap out swap in new data so now
that i've fit my model i want to know
when wales comes to visit england who's
going to win
uh
and i can do that so p so i open my
model again just as if i was going to
add more variables to it except now i
call set data and then i
i set
um
all i'm doing all i'm adding here are
indices i'm pulling out the index
corresponding to england and wales
adding one to home team one to away team
and then i call sample posterior
predictive
and then i pull out the values
and those are posterior predictive
distributions of scores
of england playing whales
presumably at wembley or something right
so
england's going to win apparently
and and and what you can do is pair wise
subtract or not subtract but um
do the you know calculate a boolean for
when the home is greater than the away
and take their mean and so this
implies an 82 percent probability of
england winning
but this is my it's kind of a dumb
simple model
the one that's on our website uses a
hierarchical model i don't think that
will help this here we should probably
change that
that only helps when you have
imbalanced data sets really
but the idea is the same we can build a
way more complex model than this right
theta could be more nuanced than that it
could have more information about the
teams it could have we could use better
historical information somehow waiting
more recent events stuff like that so
you can always make more
and in fact i was doing like an
individual based one here for like the
pitching model right where he had
different pictures
um because every picture is going to
respond to the sticky stuff incident
differently like this guy might have
been cheating here
that sort of thing so you can always
build more complex models but that
wasn't kind of the point here
you want to learn more there's more here
including
a brand new course from
pimclabs
thomas vicki's company they've got a
course called intuitive bays where you
can
learn a little bit more about all this
stuff so if you're interested
track thomas down
he looks like that guy back there
anyway
i have
five minutes left i think so um a couple
questions
do bookmakers use pymc i know one that
does
but i'm not allowed to gamble on sports
because i work in for major league
baseball so
do they use bayesian methods probably a
lot of them probably use machine
learning i would imagine but yeah i'm
guessing i only know
one that i know for sure does but um i
would imagine that you would think this
would be a good approach for
those sorts of problems yeah and sorry
the question was do bookmakers use prime
c and i i know at least one that does
i can't tell you
any other questions yeah
uh the question was if you have
different samplers for different
variables how does that work do you do
them at the same time or sequentially
prime c will
so hmc happens all at once you walk over
the entire multi-dimensional space
if i had a discrete variable in there i
would have a mixture of metropolis and
hmc and it would do one than the other
i'm not sure what which order it would
do it so it would condition on one
and it gets very sketchy when you do
these mixed ones i don't think there's
been a lot of research into what that
does to the convergence because the
it'll change the geometry when you kind
of modify the model outside of the hmc
but sometimes it works i've done it a
few times and i've gotten good results
so from a pragmatic sense it seems to
work
i would imagine if you had a lot of
discrete variables it would be harder
but usually it's like one variable that
has to be discrete and so
and it tends to work so but that's just
based on my experience
uh maybe two more yes one at the back
yeah it wouldn't be a strength
oops it wouldn't be a strength of this
um i would see how it goes if there was
a lot of data for example
um but yeah you might then look at
tree-based models or something yeah yeah
one more question yeah
a cluster of cpus not out of the box it
uses gpus now under jacks thomas can you
answer that about clusters
so the answer was version 4.1 we'll help
you more with that
yeah
all right i think we're done so but feel
free to
talk to thomas or i
sometime during the conference hope to
see you out there thanks a lot